Én már az első betegségem első évében
azt mondtam, hogy annyit éltem, mint
azelőtt az összes
életemben, merthogy olyan intenzitással.
Ezt egy nagyon-nagyon erős élményem
volt, mikor banálisnak tűnik egy
alkalommal már mikor sugárkezelésről
jöttünk haza, és a mostani párom hozott
haza, ő felajánlotta volt, hogy akkor
még nem voltunk kapcsolatban, de hogy
felajánlotta, hogy ő segít, ő is egy
csillag az életemben. És megálltunk
szovátán, és akkor kezdtek árulni ilyen
kürtös kalácsba. Ö. fag fagyit. Igen. És
megvettünk egy-egy fagyit, tehát hogy
nem egy gombócot, hanem tele azt a
kürtöskalácsot. És ahogy leültem az első
padra, és ahogy csöpögött a a fagylalt a
könyökemen, és csorgott, és ettem a
fagyit, és egy olyan erős
életérzés, hogy istenem, én most eszem
ezt a fajlalt, üllök, itt süt a nap,
mellettem egy egy ember, akinek
számítok, és hogy olyan csodálatos érzés
volt.
[Zene]